Brian we're of course all rooting for
our golden knights here at home watch
parties are happening all over the
valley tonight Sasha Loftus joins us
from downtown Summerlin where things are
just getting started ahead of game three
hi Sasha
hey Vanessa yeah about an hour from puck
drop and look at how crowded it is here
in downtown Summerlin everyone is just
really excited for game three all those
fans that couldn't make it out there to
Florida are happy to cheer on our nights
from here at home now you can see this
kind of sea of golden knights gear a lot
of different people with some fun
outfits a lot of glitter some capes some
Flags we're seeing dogs we're seeing
kids we're seeing people playing hockey
out here which is pretty awesome so
there's a DJ as you can hear some
pre-game fun there's also snacks and
drinks from local food trucks there's
merch and you can see the games being
broadcast on all these different trucks
here with those big screens now we're
told of course this is supposed to
continue through the night there also
will be a couple uh free giveaways some
surprises for fans who've made the Trek
out here and hey it already is as you
can see super crowded but more and more
people are just kind of trickling in and
we expect them to get here through the
next hour and even after the game starts
we'll be out here all evening long of
course bringing you the latest here from
downtown Summerlin for now reporting
live Sasha Loftus 8 News Now